i'm really excited about meeting the
next person who's coming on the news
rossi
she resigned her job as an assistant
principal right and that
launched her brand new business which
was a spice shop
and now she's making it her mission to
help other female entrepreneurs follow
their dreams too
please welcome the owner of the spice
suite
angel gregario angel
angel mario i'm so excited to meet you
look at you thank you peace how are you
i was so excited to meet you because i
do
think that what you have done with your
life
is the blueprint and the example and i
would love you
to teach us and tell us what inspired
you to take this huge leap
and leave the job that you had to pursue
the one you wanted
so i have always been like a risk taker
i have i mean sometimes that was just me
being rebellious in school and not
listening and
bucking the dress code i had no idea
though that it would land me as a spice
girl owning a spice shop
because i was just leaving a nail salon
and saw a felice sign
called the landlord and like any good
landlord he wanted to know well what do
you want to do with my space
and i was like oh i have no idea i just
want to know the rent and so he said
we're looking to make a decision
in a couple days and i said okay okay
okay i want to open a spice shop can you
just tell me the price
so in so many ways i am really living a
dream i didn't even know i had
um and i'm so grateful like this journey
has been absolutely life-changing
how did you turn this idea of spice shop
into a seven-figure business
ah i could i'm not by myself first um
i have tried women um that i
affectionately call
spice girls they're part of this spice
girl and tribe and they are
19 black women who are also business
owners but they don't have a brick and
mortar shop
but they support me and running my
business so i have this unique business
model that i i'm
coined called black and forth where i
invite black
small business owners to share space
with me and they can do pop-up shops
here completely free of charge
and after doing so many pop-up shops
we've hosted over 450 pop-up shops so
far wow
and then the first girl was like well
can i come again and she kept wanting to
come back
and i said hey i kind of trust you i
think you trust me
how about the next time you come and pop
up i don't have to be here can you run
the shop for me
and she agreed and i thought like i
wonder how many other folks would like
to do that like we can just kind of
barter
these beautiful women who you see um all
agreed to do it and i host monthly
professional development where we invite
other black women experts to teach us
everything we need to know from taxes
accounting
um trademarking everything um that is
how
as an educator that's kind of how i pull
back into them by hosting these
professional developments
in collaboration with other black women
experts you are the epitome
of a good person smart business
taking the risk having it pay off
building a community lifting others up
the list
is endless uh one detail that i really
loved was that you've
traveled to continue to enhance your
knowledge and love of spices do you
have any recommendations for all of us
who can't go anywhere right now on how
to spruce up our spices
for folks who are at home one you can
order from the spice suite we offer
spice boxes
twice a month and that's probably the
easiest way if you can't get into our
physical space here in d.c we're still
open
but i tell people like my motto here is
food is fashion
and i take that seriously because i
don't take
food or fashion super seriously i think
that if you love it you use it on what
you love
a lot of folks come to me and they're
like okay well what do you recommend for
chicken and salmon
i'm like well first of all i don't know
you so i don't know what you want your
chicken
what i know is that you should have fun
and go for it and take a risk and try
something if it speaks to you
then let's just try it if it's nasty
we'll try something else the next
time advice in the kitchen is really to
take the risk have all the fun
don't think so hard and the same way i
tell people when you're in your closet
just wear it don't wait for a special
occasion i would have worn this
whether it was talking to you or going
to the supermarket everything you've
said today and everything you're doing
with your life is just
something that we're so honored to talk
about here at the show i can't thank you
enough
you are an angel and thank you for
spicing up
the news today but more importantly life
itself yeah
so i appreciate it go to our website at
the drewberrymarshow.com
see how you can support the spice sweet
and the spice girls i know i'll be there
angel is the embodiment of black girl
magic
and i appreciate angel for as she grew
her own business
always bringing us along and sharing the
resources to level up our businesses as
well
the spy suite is our home she shows that
the impossible
is possible the spy suite is an amazing
place
it's really transformed my business and
i'm truly appreciative
spice girling has become a major part of
my life
she shares her time her expertise her
space
her network thank you so much for being
the
the wonderful person that you are